so we are approaching official summer
but a lot of companies are looking to
hire help for the summer season that
hiring though has not been easy no it's
just this this thing that has dragged on
now for a couple years mary jane
belliesa joining us live at a local
business on sahara and tanea and they're
having a hard time finding workers
yeah that's right heather like many
other businesses huntington jewelers is
looking to hire more people and they're
preparing to open a second location soon
and with summer approaching they
anticipated to be busy with the start of
wedding season while the family-owned
business is looking to hire people to
fill various positions they say it's not
just about hiring people but finding the
right fit for long-term employment and
they're not the only company looking to
do so local hospitality coach michelle
klein says it's all about changing the
company culture
when your team member when your new hire
feels the love in the first 90 days and
then you have that progressive
you know becoming part of the family
type of mentality
then they are going to stick around
small family-owned business here and we
have our own culture in this company so
you know feeling out if you're a right
fit for us
so it's not just can you do the job
right
but can you fit in with us
klein adds the hospitality industry has
been hit hard she says some businesses
have resorted to automation and
eliminated positions to cut costs making
it difficult for job seekers to find
work and for companies to keep employees
now huntington jewelers is looking to
hire half a dozen people for their
second location this summer reporting
live mary jane valeza live local now